Let's talk about this.
Honestly, it really depends
on the size of your data.
For small amounts of binary data,
very, very small amounts of binary data,
you could actually put
the raw data in the database.
There are blob types, and those
are supported and work pretty well.
However, as you start putting
larger data into the database,
it gets pretty inefficient
and you end up writing
a lot more code.
Well, as far as storing the files
in a public folder
on the device is concerned,
well, that might work if you
actually wanted to share those files.
But, typically, you don't want to share
those files with other applications,
so storing them in a public folder
on the device isn't a very good idea.
But the third option is pretty good.
Storing the files in a private folder
and then referencing
the location in the database.
Now, admittedly, you might not even need
to put them into the database at all.
But it's often nice to do this if you need
to do any kind of queries on them.
You can store metadata in your database
and store files in a private folder.
This is what Android does in the gallery.